bruno retailleau lui va quitter la
présidence des pays de la loire il va
rester au sénat c'est ce qu'annonce
ouest france
on le savait on s'en doutait comment est
ce que vous les appréciez ces prénoms
moi j'ai pas apprécié je dis simplement
il s'est passé la même chose pour
christian estrosi
je pense qu'il faut faire attention dû
jouer au bonneteau électorale et que
lorsque lorsqu'on se présente à la
présidence d'une région
en principe c'est pour six ans c'est pas
pour y rester ou pas y rester en
fonction des élections mais moi j'ai du
respect pour bruno retailleau qui vient
coller que je connais bien mais vous
allez devenir un homme
oui parce que je parle par rapport aux
gens si on veut réhabiliter la politique
ce n'est pas une fois qu'on est sur un
poste on doit on doit y rester mais si
je comprends qu'ils fassent le choix du
national par rapport aux régionales il a
été directeur de campagne de son désir
de françois fillon il est il incarne
cette ligne politique peut-être
sera-t-il candidat à la présidence des
républicains nous verrons bien